الاوضاع اقل ما يمكن ان توصل به انها
ماساويه المواطنين يعيشون هنا وضعا صعبا
جدا المدينه تفتقد الى الكهرباء الى
الكهرباء والمياه والغاز والتدفئه وحتى
شبكه الاتصالات نحن مضطرين ان نكون في
مباشره من هذا المكان لانه المكان الوحيد
الذي فيه يعني شبكه شبكه اتصال ضعيفه جدا
كما تشاهد هنا هؤلاء المواطنين ياتون الى
هنا ليستطيع التواصل مع من يرغبون في
التواصل معه خارج هذه المدينه كما تشاهد
همم هنا يقفون يحاولون استخدام الهواتف
والتحدث الى اهلهم والى اصدقائهم خارج
المدينه
هو الحاكم في هذه
المقاطعه الحاكم العسكري في المقطعه همم
منذ الامس حتى اليوم كان هنالك حوالي همم
34 جريحا وسبعت قتلى نتيجه الضربات
ملوخيه
والقذائف التي سقطت في المدينه قبل دقائق
قليله فقط كان هنالك قضيه سقطا بالقرب من
المتجر الوحيد الذي يعمل ويمكن المواطنين
على الحصول منه على المواد الغذائيه
سقطايفه قتل شخص بالقرب من المتجر كان يقف
الشرطيه طارت واصابه هذا المواطن
وقتل في هذه الحادثه همم يعني الوضع صعب
جدا في المدينه قبل قليل ايضا يعني ناشد
المواطنين هنا في هذه الساحه عن همم يحاول
ان ينتقلوا الى مدن قريبه من هنا يعني
يكون فيها بعض الخدمات قال من لا يستطيع
ان ينتقم ان يستطيع ان نوفر له السكن على
نفقه الدوله والاطعام وايضا الترحيل يمكن
ان يكون على نفقه الدوله ناشد المواطنين
بانها المدينه ما زال غير امنه كنا في
دوله قبل قليل يعني شاهدنا المناطق التي
تضرر في المدينه هنالك دمار واسع في هذه
المدينه وهنالك مناطق كثيره ما ز ملغمه
والقوات غير قادره الان اول المتخصصين غير
قادرين على تفكيك الالغام في جميع هذه
المناطق هم يعملون في المناطق التي يكون
فيها احتكاك مباشر للمواطنين او تواجد
للمدنيين ويتركون الاماكن الاخرى
والمؤسسات الاخرى لوقت لاحق لان العدد
قليل وايضا لا يوجد فنيين بالقدره الكافي
مقابل العدد همم
القنادل ايضا كنا قبل قليل في المناطق
التي تواجد فيها القوات الروسيه والقوات
السودانيه ومركز القياده ايضا وجدنا طبعا
الاثار هناك وجدنا المستشفى الذي كان يعني
يعالجون فيه الجرحى تركوا كل شيء خلفه
وغادروا بعد ان قامت القوات الروسيه
هذا المكان من انظمه هاي مارس كما افادني
الجنود المتواجدين هناك في هذا المكان